bueno según el gobierno unas 80.000
familias podrían verse afectadas de
forma directa por el paso de este
huracán pero habrá un billón y medio de
personas expuestas durante la lluvia de
los próximos días de amenaza del huracán
en desarrollo se ciñe sobre una
población que todavía como bien lo
mencionaba no se recupera del impacto de
esta la semana pasada recordemos que hay
más de 1800 viviendas totalmente
destruidas y 8.000 que sufrieron daños
parciales de esto como resultado del
paso del huracán está en el caribe de
nicaragua apenas esta semana había
comenzado a fluir la ayuda humanitaria
hacia esta zona porque hay existen al
menos 25 ríos importantes que habían
mostrado su crecida y que hasta ahora
han comenzado a reducir su caudal y
también existen muchísimas personas en
los albergues que quedaron habilitados
desde la semana pasada